Tình thường tinh từ công an tình lai châu và chương ngày 20, tâm tăng sâu năm 2020, trong khi làm những vụ tình trả,
kìm sất đảm bảo an ninh chực tự tại đi bản sả mử sỏ. Tình lai châu,
tổ công tác của phòng cạnh xác gia thông, công an tình lai châu đã phát hiện hai xem may có giống hiệu bị phản pháp lực xa thông.
Tổ công tác ra hiệu lệng dùng phương tịt đi kìm trả, tinh yên, các đối tượng không chấp hành mả bất nửa tăng ra bỏ trẻ.
Một đối tượng đã lao thằng xe và đồng xí hà văn mình, các mộ chức tiếp tục hiện hiệu lệng dùng xe khiến anh bị thường nạ.
Ngay sau khi sự việc xe ra, đồng độ đã hình chương đường xí hà văn mình đi cấp kữ,
mọi giúp đã được tập tự ý bác sĩ bình biển đào qua tình lai châu và bình biển viện viện đức tận tình kìm chứ.
Nhưng sau biết thường quan hạc anh đã chút thời thường của cùng và lúc tắm giờ bà phút ngày 20, tâm bệnh năm 2020.
Chức sửi xin anh dũ của đồng xí, ngày 12, tâm bệnh năm 2020, đại tự lùng tâm quan,
ủy vinh bộ chiến sị, bộ chiến bộ công an đặt kì cứ định truy thang cấp bật hàng từ đã ý lên tiêu tá cho đồng xí hà văn mình.
Đồng thời, công an tình lai châu đá hoàn thiện hồ sơ bảo ca bộ công an chiến chú tích nước xem sép,
chỉ tặng hình chương bảo vệ tổ quốc hạng mà được với đồng xí.
Sử dây đi của tiêu tá hà văn mình là một mất mắt lớn đường với gia đình, đồng đội và tòa lực lượng công an nhân dân.
Nhưng hơn hết, đó là mình chính xong đồng cho tình thần chắc nhận, làm giống cảm và sự tận tự với tổ quốc.
Bởi nhân dân, những giả chị có loại đã và đăng được hồn đúc qua tự về hệ chiến sĩ công an.